Вітаю!
Це - єдине слово, яке син українського військовополоненого Ганс Загрудний
знає рідною мовою батька.
Хоча в Україні 90-річний ювіляр ніколи не був.
Це моя родина ось тут. Мій тато, мама...
Батько Ганса, Іван Загрудний, народився на Херсонщині,
у селищі Верхній Рогачик,
і потрапив у полон під час Першої світової війни.
Вийшовши з табору, працював спершу перукарем у Нюрнберзі,
а потім переїхав до Вецлара, де познайомився з майбутньою дружиною.
Після одруження молода родина вирішила поїхати до України.
Мама була вражена людьми
і неймовірною природою цієї країни, згадує Ганс.
Коли мама із татом були в Україні,
вони ходили гуляти біля Дніпра.
Вони дуже багато розповідали про цю річку,
яка повільно простягається українськими низинами.
Проте через складну політичну ситуацію в Україні у ті часи,
окрема Голодомор, сім’я повернулася до Німеччини.
Батько помер молодим, згадує Ганс,
йому виповнилося лише 52 роки.
Тож, розпитати про часи, проведені батьком у таборі,
Ганс особливо не встиг.
Про свого батька я знаю дуже мало.
Вони з мамою були дуже зайняті на роботі.
Хоча, мушу зізнатися, я його мало розпитував.
Маленьким хлопчиком я не надто цікавився своїми батьками.
Але зараз, звісно, шкодую, що тоді
не розпитував його більше.
Загалом до німецького та австрійського полону
під час Першої світової війни, за оцінками істориків,
потрапили десятки тисяч українців.
Серед таборів, де утримувалися українські бранці,
був табір у місті Вецлар.
Фактично, це було "місто в місті",
адже на той час у Вецларі проживали 13 тисяч жителів,
і приблизно стільки ж полонених перебували у таборі.
Нині про ті часи нагадує меморіальний комплекс,
який складається з кладовища
та пам’ятника померлим українським військовополоненим.
Його встановили у 1919-му -
частково коштом самих бранців.
Вони також брали участь у створенні меморіалу.
Майже сторічний пам’ятник тепер потребує реставрації -
з плином часу він руйнується,
до того ж після реконструкції вулиці меморіал опинився фактично у ямі.
Місцевий активіст Володимир Чернов,
який не один рік опікується долею меморіалу,
пропонує перенести пам’ятник на інше місце,
щоб захистити монумент від подальшого руйнування.
Його слід витягти із землі і поставити на належне місце,
щоб до нього можна було підійти та відійти -
тобто зробити усе відповідно до задуму автора,
яким він його бачив у міському середовищі.
Зараз пам’ятник у ямі,
цоколь закопаний приблизно на 80-90 сантиметрів,
що абсолютно неприйнятно.
Водночас кладовищу, на думку Чернова,
слід повернути історичну назву - "українське"
замість сучасної офіційної "кладовище військовополонених" -
та перепланувати його, встановивши там новий пам’ятник у вигляді кобзаря.
Проект передає ідею самих ув’язнених.
Мені вона дуже близька, тому що це кобзар,
тобто дуже мирний образ, це люди, які не хочуть війни
Це - символ миру, до якого прагнуть люди,
які розуміють, що таке війна.
Однак усе це поки лишається тільки на папері,
адже вартість лише проектувальних робіт
перевищує тридцять тисяч євро,
а виконання може коштувати у рази більше.
Однак Чернов переконаний:
у цьому має бути зацікавлена і Німеччина, і Україна.
Адже цей комплекс повинен не лише вшанувати українських воїнів,
які поклали тут своє життя,
але й стати нагадуванням про те,
що таке більше не має повторитися.